[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 échos à
l'occasion du salon de l'automobile qui
se déroule du 1er au 7 au 16 octobre
nous avons décidé de consacrer les
missions au parc automobile de
l'agglomération premier département de
france dans le domaine avec des
entreprises comme le technocentre
renault ou encore nissan et des pme qui
gravitent autour
il est important de faire un point sur
ce secteur d'activité alors quels sont
les enjeux
sommaire nous irons au salon de l'auto
interview frédéric robin il est le
directeur de l'entreprise des trois
situés à queue en cours la pme est
spécialisée dans l'ingénierie automobile
nous ferons un point avec lui focus sur
l'estac à cette école
arrivé il ya un an à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines forme des
futurs ingénieurs automobiles avec ton
bol de recherche l'école est à la pointe
de la technologie
et puis nous ferons un point sur
l'événement versailles grand parc qui
s'est déroulé le 17 septembre dernier le
public a pu découvrir les énergies de
demain sur les forces du parc automobile
saint quentinois et dans les yvelines
les yvelines c'est le premier
département automobile de france c'est
aussi celui qui dépose le plus de
brevets dans le domaine des transports
le territoire regroupe 150 entreprises
automobiles constitué de constructeurs
des équipementiers et de bureaux
d'études
au total le secteur emploie plus de 45
mille salariés les plus grandes
entreprises de l'automobile sont dans
notre région comme le technocentre
renault à guyancourt bmw france et
mercedes benz à montigny le bretonneux
nissan west europe à boise un peugeot
citroën automobile a visit
vélizy-villacoublay ou encore chrysler a
trap avec toutes ces entreprises sur le
territoire est naturel que beaucoup s'y
implantent alors quels sont les
avantages de travailler dans le premier
département automobile de france
frédéric robin dirigeants de
l'entreprise détroit spécialisée dans
l'ingénierie automobile
nous répond au micro de wilfrid reach et
nous sommes donc au mondial de
l'automobile à paris porte de versailles
en compagnie de frédéric robin bonjour
vous êtes le dirigeant de cette société
détroit détroit qui est créée en 2008 et
qui regroupe cette société aujourd'hui
présente et nous un petit peu votre
société
bonjour le groupe des 3 en fait est
composé de sept sociétés on et principe
la majorité notre activité et sur
guyancourt dans les yvelines
toutes ces sociétés aujourd'hui
travaille principalement pour le monde
de l'automobile
d'où ma présence ici et après il ya un
certain nombre d'autres structures qui
travaillent pour le groupe et aussi à
l'étranger on est aussi présent à los
angeles avec vinitech est aussi une
entité vinitech en france qui s'occupe
de la restauration de vieilles voitures
créneau c'est le design automobile pour
s'impliquer un peu de manière très
générale c'est le design automobile la
maquette automobile le concept car
donc on va vraiment du dessin jusqu'à la
voiture roulante votre présence
aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est pour parler
business pour voir un petit peu ce qui
serait aussi chez les autres voilà voir
ce qui se fait chez les autres voir des
clients voir nos réalisations aussi
comment elles sont présentées on a fait
pour citroën le concept car c'est
l'expérience qu'a été dévoilé il ya une
petite heure et mais évidemment c'est du
business
par rapport à votre implantation sur
saint quentin en yvelines qui est une
terre où la plupart des grands
constructeurs sont présents j'imagine
que c'est pas anodin expliquez-nous un
petit peu ce positionnement sur cette
agglomération
sait on est nous dans un business qui
est un vrai business de géographie
notre activité est l'activité de nos
concurrents on est tous dans un rayon de
5 km autour des constructeurs
automobiles que sont psa et renault
il ya deux grands constructeurs en
france renault et psa et tout le monde
dans le design travail autour des
constructeurs on veut travailler
justement avec vous les démarches et ils
vous sollicite com comment ça se passe
un petit peur en coulisse qu'on
comprenne un peu des deux il ya
nécessairement un petit peu de démarches
après ils nous connaissent ils
connaissent nos compétences ils
connaissent notre savoir faire ils
viennent nous voir avec des projets
c'est toujours des appels d'offres on
est en concurrence avec les gens qui ont
le même métier dans le coin et puis on
répond et puis après c'est que le
meilleur gagne
sur les yvelines généralement le
département est le premier département
automobile et un fort soutien à la
filière il y aussi ce projet bd comme
qui se développent du côté de satory
vous y êtes impliqué dessus comment vous
travaillez pas particulièrement nous on
est au plus près des constructeurs donc
on y est impliqué à travers les
constructeurs mais pas en direct on n'a
pas vocation nous à s'impliquer dans ce
style de projets directement mais on le
sera par l'intermédiaire de peugeot par
l'intermédiaire citroën ou par
l'intermédiaire de renault au travers de
leur implication dans ce projet vous
voyez aujourd'hui ce mondial de
l'automobile qui est outil important
pour de nombreuses marques qui se
renouvelle un petit peu je pense à
citroën que vous avez mentionné mais qui
qui communique sur ce renouvellement
vous vous dites qu'il ya de belles
perspectives l'évolution du marché
automobile ouais l'évolution est plutôt
positive après ce qu'on a vécu en 2008
et en 2012 un peu compliqué aussi
aujourd'hui c'est très positif il ya une
marque renault qui est extrêmement
dynamique en design comme le disait
carlos ghosn à sa conférence de presse
il a trente nouveaux modèles en quatre
ans c'est colossal
mais c'est vrai un peu pour tout le
monde aussi toutes les marques sont
plutôt dans une dynamique assez positif
dire que l'automobile ne souffre plus
finalement
elle souffre différemment devant les
difficultés alors c'est toujours un peu
la même chose c'est les difficultés de
placement le véhicule autonome c'est une
vraie tendance tous les gens ont
tendance à y aller il ya déjà des offres
il y en aura d'autres demain il ya ça
nécessite un renouvellement on voit que
l'automobile dur de moins en moins
longtemps une voiture elle sort elle est
renouvelée au bout de trois ans elle est
arrêtée au bout de 6
avant ça dure et une twingo elle a été
produite pendant 14 ans c'est quelque
chose qui n'arrivera plus c'est du
business pour nous tant mieux parce que
quelque part pour new line twingo c'est
une catastrophe une voiture qui dure 14
ans pendant 14 ans travaillent pas donc
tant mieux pour nous d'un certain côté
mais c'est aussi beaucoup de difficultés
parce que le changement de mode de
consommation de l'automobile un pack
très fortement le design et ça c'est une
donnée qui est super intéressante
perspective de développement justement
d'embauché on embauche régulièrement le
groupe ya dix ans vous et 80 personnes
aujourd'hui on est 100 personnes
donc c'est pas une croissance incroyable
c'est petit à petit après on développe
aussi beaucoup l'étranger notamment à
los angeles comme je vous disais parce
que il ya deux constructeurs en france
tous les autres sont présents à los
angeles donc on va chercher les autres
aussi pour essayer un jour de les faire
venir en france
on y arrive on travaille pour tout le
monde on est vraiment un un sous
traitant
on va dire le plus mondial possible on
travaille pour tous les constructeurs
japonais
on essaye de travailler avec la majorité
des constructeurs allemands donc
l'objectif c'est de développer le
business clairement merci beaucoup
frédéric robin qui est donc le dirigeant
de cette entreprise
détroit le 7-8 échos qui se poursuit en
plateau avec vous au smad merci où il
fait de réchy on ne peut pas parler
automobile sans évoquer le cadre de
l'estaca situe à saint quentin en
yvelines cette école forme des
ingénieurs de demain
faisons un point sur cet établissement
qui a un temps d'avancé voiture autonome
électriques ou encore intelligence
artificielle
voici les sujets d'étude de la voiture
de demain sur lequel blanche les
enseignants chercheurs de l'estaca mais
le projet le plus ambitieux c'est la
voiture autonome le vécu longtemps mais
nous on cherche donc à le alpha faire
fonction de véhicules dans un situation
de conduite urbaine périodes 1 sans
l'intervention du conducteur pour
assurer un confort et puis augmenter la
sécurité des usagers du de la route et
pour créer la voiture du futur il y a
les enseignants-chercheurs bien sûr mais
aussi des 1800 étudiants de l'estaca
grâce aux associations de l'université
ils peuvent laisser libre cours à leur
imagination comme avec cette association
qui a créé une voiture de course pour
des compétitions
l'association c'est un moyen de
d'appliquer les cours les cours en école
d'ingénieur reste théorique et faire
partie d'une association comme celle ci
permet de pratiquer en fait mais
cependant on apprend de nous mêmes on se
renseigne beaucoup et on est beaucoup en
autonomie le record du monde par exemple
en de tout véhicule électrique ont fondu
et détenus par une forme formula student
donc c'est une seconde 6 au 0 à 100
donc ce sont des voitures 4,6 des
renforts qui ont une très bonne agilité
en virage
une très bonne adhérence et des projets
fous de l'estaca intéresse les
professionnels comme psa renault ou
encore fiat qui n'hésite pas à recruter
les élèves dès la sortie de l'école
l'estaca collabore avec beaucoup
d'entreprises et d'instituts comme bd
comme ce nom ne vous dit peut-être rien
et pourtant
l'institut travaille avec psa renault ou
encore le groupe ça prend le but de cet
organisme créé en 2014 et de concevoir
des véhicules propres et durables
vd comme en chiffres c'est 300 millions
de dotations sur dix ans 125
collaborateurs et 7000 m² d'ateliers et
des bureaux dédiés à la recherche
l'énergie de demain
vd comme travail sur le sujet mais
d'autres sont dans la course et le grand
public a pu les découvrir à depuis
découvrir leur travail lors d'un
événement organisé par versailles grand
parc le 17 septembre dernier
alors qu'est ce qui va remplacer votre
carburant demain la réponse dans ce
reportage
à travers des animations des
démonstrations et également des essais
le public a pu découvrir les innovations
et avancées technologiques de demain
notamment le smart grid développé par vd
com qui permet de stocker l'énergie des
voitures ici c'est comment on peut
stocker l'énergie
il ya deux types de stockage rhin
stockage court terme c'est à dire par
exemple tout simplement en rechargeant
les batteries d'un véhicule électrique
tout comme vous rechargez les batteries
de votre smartphone tous les jours c'est
un moyen de stocker de l'énergie
à côté on travaille sur le saccage long
terme qui est par exemple fabriquer de
l'eau en hydrogène bd comme a décidé
d'utiliser ce système à hydrogène pour
des vélos mais d'autres sont allés plus
loin comme la société hype qui a décidé
de créer des taxis à hydrogène
c'est le véhicule du futur c'est le
véhicule du futur parce que là sur les
véhicules électriques
l'inconvénient c'est la recharge qui
prend des heures où ça se chiffre en
heures donc pour pouvoir recharger avoir
une recharge complète donc là une
recharge sur ce type de véhicule se fait
sur le côté donc on a un réservoir
d'hydrogène donc la recherche effectuée
en boule peu après cinq minutes ou part
sur une autonomie de quasiment 500 km
vécu très propre qui ne rejette que de
la vapeur d'eau
sachez qu'une flotte de taxis à
hydrogène est déjà en circulation dans
paris
pour en savoir plus rendez vous sur le
site www.halde.fr et place à l'agenda
échos trois dates à noter on commence
avec open innovation qui est un espace
d'échangé entre entreprises le but
donner une nouvelle dimension à votre
stratégie
le rendez vous c'est le 7 octobre
prochain de 8h30 à 18h campus hec paris
à juin aux as on passe à rendez-vous
création l'événement permet d'en
apprendre plus sur l'étude de marché et
comment se réaliser soi même ça sera le
4 octobre de 14h30 à 16h à la maison de
l'entreprise à montigny le bretonneux
et puis pour finir le 6 octobre un
atelier de développement vous aidera à
construire une stratégie performante
c'est le 7 octobre de 9h30 à 11h à la
maison de l'entreprise à montigny le
bretonneux 7,8 écossais fini prochain
rendez vous le 13 octobre le numéro sera
consacré aux sky is business day
l'événement qui se déroulera au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pernaut
entreprises de pouvoir échanger entre
elles bonne soirée
[Musique]